before I actually there you go I said
we're gonna do two things today and
they're both about the scripture so the
second thing under a good frequency
distribution table which is what you're
constructing right now is something
you've put off before it's called a
stem-and-leaf plot now could you raise
your hand if that phrase rings a bell
okay thank you here's them now you've
seen stem-and-leaf plots before maybe
you didn't realize the stem-and-leaf
plots are just this it's a kind of way
to group data together okay yeah don't
freak out I'm going to put this table
back in about five minutes once I'm done
so you know you'll see it again but I
want to show you what we would do if we
took the same data and instead made a
stem-and-leaf plot okay so this is kind
of what it's heavily for looks like
again you've got a left-hand part which
is like the beginnings of your numbers
and then you've got the end part which
is the final digit of whatever these
scores are okay so hopefully as I start
to construct this wing a bit ago now the
important thing you need to remember
it's just like this scientific notation
there are sort of rules around this to
make it consistent from leaves leaves it
they've always got a one digit one okay
now these are all three-digit numbers
okay so if my leaves are one digit how
BIG's the stem down a bit it's got to be
the other two okay so I look at all of
these numbers and I'm saying what's the
smallest number
I think the smallest number is a hundred
and eighty something where is it there
it is Vicki one of these expects the
smallest number I can see to the bottom
of my range and the highest number is
250 something I think 250 exactly there
okay yeah good so 250 something that's
the highest number so therefore for my
stems okay these are the stems I'm going
to write up my my smallest one is going
to be 18 because a hundred and eighty
something
question yeah maybe leave some space and
then come back
I will I will shut all of these so if
you don't get to do it right now
it'll be been there in a minute 18 19 20
21 22 23 24 and 25 now I've been a bit
naughty because I've said it as 18 19 20
etcetera it's actually 180 190 something
250 something so he's the first two
digits are the three-digit number
now I'm going to do just fine I did
before I'm going to go through this data
these are my groups these are my classes
okay all the numbers in the 100's
all the numbers in the 190s and so on
and this time instead of just doing
Italian I'm actually going to drive his
numbers down okay so again from the
beginning
the first one is 244 so which stem am I
going to go to the 24 good the second
last one and I'm gonna say 4 uh yeah
I'll get to that in a second so this is
a regular stem and leaf plot there is an
ordered similarly popping what's your
five years what makes most sets is to
make this the number one first and then
work worried about the order because
otherwise well you'll see what will
happen remember the important thing is
I'm I don't wanna miss any data right so
remember I had 244 so I'm just gonna go
systematically from the top left to
right etcetera so my next one is 220 220
230 to again this is a somewhat lengthy
process so once you finish this you're
going to get something like this okay
all right now you can see this is not in
order
I don't we plan it out right this is a
bit of a sort of dogs breakfast team
later on we will use stem and leaf plots
to work out these things called the
median quartiles etc and you need two
numbers in order to do that so I'm not
ready for this but can you see like in
order to do this in order from the first
time I need to know what every single
number over here is unlike I have to go
through every one of them first whereas
now I could say alright I'm just going
to go 0 and then a 1 and then there's a
to actually to 0 sorry and so on so I'll
take this and then I'll put it into
water ok so this is a stem and leaf plot
and
I hope you can see just look at that for
a second and compare it to the Tally's
that you were making before okay you're
presenting the same Donna you should see
the same kind of humps and costes and
that kind of thing okay
what other super cool thing about seven
o'clock ok now you can actually just
turn your page around when you've done
this but when I turn my iPad the screen
stays the same so instead I'm going to
do this the stem-and-leaf plot is
actually two graphs in one because if
you look at it carefully and turn your
page around what you've actually created
is not just a seminary plot but let me
fill it in for you this is a bar graph
right look you've just created another
representation that again helps you see
the patterns in the data that's what
it's all about
ok so what you need to do is just turn
your head and there it is